the bioeconomy includes the production
of food
materials and energy from renewable
biological resources
these economic sectors depend upon
healthy ecosystems
it's vital to monitor and predict
environmental impacts of the bioeconomy
life cycle assessment known as lca is a
standardized methodology
that assesses the environmental impacts
of a system's life cycle
from the extraction of raw materials to
end of life management
the life cycle of a bio-based product
includes
primary production manufacturing and
processing
retail and use end of life management
and the associated distribution and
transport
lca quantifies different environmental
and human health impacts
that happen in different stages of the
life cycle
lca methods can be used to support
policy making in two main ways
the regulatory approach supports the
implementation of specific legislative
instruments
it should be exact well defined and
easy to calculate why
to allow for comparisons
the strategic approach assesses
large-scale impacts across
economic sectors geographic areas
and ecological processes
to avoid any unintended consequences of
policy decisions
however results of both approaches could
be misinterpreted
and misused to avoid this lca
practitioners
must communicate clearly on the scope
assumptions and limitations of each
study
and the importance of applying the right
approach to assess sustainability
and highlight trade-offs the use of lca
methods helps to ensure a sustainable
and circular bioeconomy
where socioeconomic benefits go hand in
hand
with healthy ecosystems
download the full brief and discover
more at the knowledge center for
bioeconomy website